another deadline come and gone in the
battle between congressional Republicans
and the Justice Department over access
to information about alleged
infiltration of the Trump presidential
campaign chief intelligence correspond
to catherine herridge is here with an
update seems like we're going into these
deadlines all the time
well that's right Brendon good evening
the FBI director and Deputy Attorney
General are now scheduled to testify
publicly on Capitol Hill Thursday as a
pitched battle over FBI records further
escalates the allegation levelled by
some Republicans is that the official
July 2016 timeline for when the Russia
case began conflicts with records that
suggests the FBI began gathering
intelligence much earlier than publicly
acknowledged I think the American people
are beginning to see what it is that
we've been after for a very long time
and that is is is it common or does it
ever happen that the counterintelligence
agencies or capabilities of this country
are they used to target political
campaigns FBI agent Peter struck who
will be deposed by lawmakers later this
week wrote the FBI memo that officially
opened the FBI Russia case on July 31st
2016 the outstanding records focus on
intelligence activities and the FBI's
alleged use of confidential human
sources to investigate Trump campaign
aides prior to that date two letters
delivered late Friday to Congress that
the FBI believes in a substantially
comply with a majority of the
committee's requests and addressed
whether the FBI utilized confidential
human sources prior to initiating that
investigation the House Intelligence
Committee said the FBI under director
Ray and DOJ under deputy attorney
general Rosenstein did not provide a
comprehensive response and the
department wrongly limits the records to
congressional leadership after the
weekend back and forth the president
took to Twitter I have tried to stay
uninvolved with the Department of
Justice and FBI although I do not
legally have to but you do have to ask
why the DOJ and FBI aren't giving over
requested documents the house
committee's ranking Democrat Adam Schiff
told Fox in a statement Republicans want
the records to help President Trump and
to undermine the credibility of the
Russia probe Justice Department
officials dismissed today's deadline as
questions asked and already answered
Bret thank you